programme de ski bonsoir j'ai 36 ans
j'ai très lecteur en chef d'une lettre
d'investigation qui s'appelle
intelligence online et vous êtes déjà
venu ici dans cette émission lors de la
publication d'un livre que vous avez
écrit avec Jean-charles Brizard c'est de
Noël qui s'appelle Ben Laden la vérité
interdite et qui sort en poche en ce
moment là vous revenez ce soir pour un
bouquin qui s'appelle l'effroyable
mensonge c'est des foutaises sur les
attentats du 11 septembre c'est aux
éditions la découverte vous savez
comment on fait attention à toi
alors ces derniers ce que vous avez
écrit en collaboration avec Jean Guisnel
du.
Thierry Meyssan il est plus à plaindre
qu'à blâmer oui je crois je crois parce
que il y a pour moi c'est la différence
entre un fou furieux et un manipulateur
le manipulateur c'est très bien ce qu'il
fait en permanence donc il
instrumentaliser des mensonges un
illuminé Marily crois et je pense que
c'est ce qu'il faisait sa force que
quand il était vraiment convaincu j'ai
vu cette émission il était vraiment
convaincu de ce qu'ils disaient et c'est
peut-être plus effrayant en sachant que
par le passé c'est quelqu'un qui tout de
même a été très écouté et notamment par
la la plupart des des médias Parisien
alors on n'est pas là ce soir pour vous
répondre de toute façon je crois qu'il
va faire un livre en réponse au vôtre
qui s'appellerait je
regrette de pas avoir pris assez de
précautions oratoires ce soir
mon amour
des romans de Philippe Cadic m'embarquer
dans une écoute peut-être un peu trop
classique de dire que j'ai regardé
l'émission qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
que tu te faut parler
la beaucoup de gens ont été abusé par
Thierry Meyssan parce que Thierry
Meyssan bah c'est quelqu'un qui
appartient la franc-maçonnerie qui a
beaucoup milité pour le droit des
homosexuels contre le Front national il
a dirigé le Réseau Voltaire c'est un
réseau d'information dans beaucoup de
gens ont été abusé par lui et que
s'est-il passé comment ce type était
crédible d'un seul coup a pu se mettre à
raconter comme vous dîtes n'importe quoi
donc je sais pas
ce qu'il a conduit finalement à ce qui
est certain c'est que je crois que
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait lui et
d'autre parce que finalement on a
découvert que il n'était pas celle en
quelque sorte ce n'était pas des gens
qui était comme il le prétend des
amoureux de la vérité de la transparence
ce sont des gens qui font commerce qui
vivent en étant persuadé qu'ils sont
entourés de complot alors je pense que
on pourrait en parler longuement aux
États-Unis c'est quelque chose de très
connu les conspirationniste les
choses de président dans le paysage
politique américain et ça pose pas de
problème parce que les frontières sont
très clairement perçue par tous le
problème c'est qu'en en France on avait
des gens comme ça qui finalement vivait
sur la conspiration qu'on avait jamais
remise en cause parce que jusqu'à
présent la conspiration dans leur bouche
elle avait bon temps elle était
politiquement correct puisque derrière
toutes les conspirations ils voyent et
finalement des mercenaires d'extrême
droite ou les les les plus vilains au
mot phobe donc finalement c'était des
gens qui était assez assez commode de
temps en temps selon selon mais à aucun
moment ils n'ont fait un travail sérieux
qui consiste à dire des documents aller
vers des informations
sur le Pentagone
à Washington
lance qui vivent près du Pentagone et
c'est vrai que quand tu es venu vous
voir au mois de décembre donc viens de
sortir son bouquin pour me dire
Guillaume il faut que je te dise un truc
en avion ne se poser sur le Pentagone je
suis resté assis au fond de mon siège
pétrifié parce qu'effectivement il y
avait tellement de gens qui étaient
autour du
Puy
du Fou
commerce donc
moi-même je ne connais rien en
balistique mais je me serais jamais
permis d'avancer un truc pareil donc on
est allé voir finalement des gens non
c'est le métier ça y est notamment déjà
en France comme Jacques Rouland le plus
grand spécialiste français des crash
aérien pour leur demander si d'aventure
un Boeing c'était cracher sur le
Pentagone est-ce que à votre avis ça
pourrait occasionner ce type de trou et
la réponse a été oui mais une fois oui
et en plus il nous a expliqué pourquoi
bah alors je vais essayer de vous faire
un devis avec un Boeing habituellement
quand il se crash dans tous les
accidents aériens d'avion civile il se
crash en plongeant à plat c'est-à-dire
que c'est un angle assez ouvert donc et
il rebondit en général sur le sol c'est
ce qui explique alors premièrement parce
que les Boeing non pas les instruments
de mort qui leur permet de voler en
piqué non heureusement pour les
passagers et donc quand il arrive au sol
il rebondit une résistance avec le sol
stick dans la plupart des accidents
aériens impliquant des avions civils en
a des
brindilles y en a des morceaux pardon
d'avion et par qui n'est pas sur
plusieurs kilomètres parce que l'avion
rebondit le deuxième titre de crash
aérien c'est ce qu'on appelle en
crachant piquer et tu sais en général
des avions militaires et donc l'avion
tombe avec un angle à 90° sur le sol et
là est-ce que votre avis l'avion il
rebondit et il part à Créteil non
l'avion il s'encastre et donc il y a un
cratère qui se forme en général pas très
profond de ça entre 5 à 10 m est le
poids du de l'avion et
l'avion sans Castres et se désintègre et
les seules choses qu'on retrouve c'est à
l'intérieur du cratère parfois des des
éléments du moteur mais on ne retrouve
rien ailleurs intéressant de savoir
c'est maintenant de reporter ces petits
problèmes de physique à l'accident du
l'attentat contre le Pentagone contre le
Pentagone on a un beau qui est allé tout
droit contre un bâtiment et pas
n'importe quel bâtiment c'est peut-être
le plus sécurisé au monde en terme de la
chaîne d'architecture se dire que le
Pentagone C5 bâtiment et c'est une
structure de béton Meylan glacier du
calcaire donc 5 bâtiment comme ça à 90°
donc qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
naturellement il apparaît Bondy et les
morceaux ils sont pas dans tous les cas
si il s'est encastré à la manière d'un
piquet exactement comme c'est ça
en fait pas besoin de ça
en fait il avait qu'à prendre ce qu'on
appelle des pistolets Glock c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont en matière synthétique et
qui sont indétectable dans les aéroports
sur à quoi vous répondez les pistolets
sont peut-être en matière synthétique
indétectable mais quand ils sont en
métal à chaque fois c'est ce qui nous a
semblé
amusant c'est c'est s'apercevoir que
chaque information été finalement piqué
dans une petite revue spécialisée
elle était très très parcellaire comme
ça et qu'elle avait été mélanger dans la
cette espèce de ben oui uniquement pour
accréditer la tête du complot mais voyez
sur cette exemple de très bête sur les
c'est pas compliqué d'aller voir quand
même soit un militaire soit
organisation qui travaille sur l'enquête
sur le FBI et
de leur demander est-ce que ça vous
semble possible et à aucun moment ce
travail se fait que non seulement ce
sont des élucubrations mais elle elle
n'a rien à aucun moment. Dans le bouquin
de Thierry Meyssan les balises été mise
à l'intérieur des tours du Wall Trade
Center écurie quitter les pilotes sont
peu habitué à faire de la proche et sur
les balises d'une part on ne sait pas si
effectivement c'est terroriste et plus
avance plus vite
très très bien organisé il allait très
bien planifié réaction de disposer pas
de balise donc nous là dessus dessous.
Là on est on est resté assez prudent en
revanche ce qu'on a permis ce qu'on a pu
recouper comme information c'est que si
vous avez eu des balises Enzo elle
aurait pas servi à grand-chose
faire plutôt à la navigation
de
configuration pour ce type d'avion
contre on va pas bien. Ça aurait pu
servir mais effectivement on peut on
peut l'immeuble numéro 7 du World Trade
Center qui s'effondre sans avoir été
percuté par un avion
à ce jour il n'existe aucune preuve que
cet immeuble ce soit effectivement il
faudrait sans avoir été percuté par un
avion et à la suite d'un événement sur
un immeuble qui a eu d'avion non mais
attendez l'immeuble est à côté donc on
ne sais pas si c'est la séquence de
l'effondrement du Wall Trade Center on
sait pas si facilement un incendie ne
s'est pas déclaré dans cet immeuble à la
suite des projections de dire que c'est
un événement qui doit technique pour
pour des experts de la police judiciaire
scientifique c'est un événement qui
nécessite plusieurs années de travail
pour l'expliquer effectivement c'est
facile d'arriver et 3 mois après d'avoir
une théorie du complot
on a pas de réponse aujourd'hui on
se
retrouve
tous les jours
responsable quand fonctionnaire du SAV
paraît-il retrouver alors quand bien
même donc déjà ça y a un problème et
quand bien même et alors quelle
conclusion en tirer le passeport de
Mohamed a été retrouvé
il est dans la poche d'un mec qui se
trouve dans les
papiers d'identité
à l'intérieur de l'avion
en arabe qui retrouver sur le siège
arrière d'une voiture sur un parking
d'aéroport en Floride écouter la en plus
c'est intéressant cette information
parce que depuis quelques jours en c'est
que le FBI avec travailler sur des
individus qui prenait des cours de
pilotage en Arizona est le bureau de
répertorier les choses très facile
là-dessus on voit bien que c'est ces
terroristes la n'avait pas besoin
d'apprendre tous les bouquins que
normalement les commandant de bord pour
mener cette action donc il est pas très
surprenant que finalement un petit
un petit mémo été rédigé dans leur
langue maternelle pour qu'il puisse se
préparer une histoire
de la Maison Blanche qui brûle le 11
septembre est-ce qu'on ait une
explication journée
non non chercher à suivre
pourquoi il taxi les théories comme
celle de Messan peuvent se propager
c'est du tout simplement au doute des
citoyens devant l'attitude des des
médias nom en premier lieu il y a un
vrai problème avec la presse
qui n'a pas fait son boulot sur cette
affaire pour les entrées simples mais
sans Thierry Meyssan Réseau Voltaire on
était légitimer par la plupart des
grands journaux parisiens qui
effectivement a l'occasion de tel ou tel
de combat sortait mais sans pour faire
une déclaration et cetera et le jour où
cette affaire est apparu tout le monde
toute la presse parisien enfin ce
qu'elle veut dire en parler et mais à
chaque fois en priant Dieu pour que ça
se fasse autour de la du bouquin mais
sans pourquoi parce que chacun voyais
bien qu'il y avait contribué pendant des
années à légitimer quelqu'un qui était
en train de péter les plombs
et sachant que c' est cette attitude est
vraiment dangereuse parce que finalement
pour éviter d'avoir à se contredire des
journalistes peuvent mettre un mouchoir
sur leur poche en disant bah voilà ça on
va pas en parler ça va pas aller dans le
décor il y a un vrai problème de la de
la Presse là-dessus
donc
ici
la semaine d'après pour lui demander si
vous trouvez ça normal
moi ça me va la formation en tant que
tel m'étonne pas tellement que tu aies
pu partir de Jalalabad au volant d'un 4
4 avec un an qu'on voit très voyant
exetera c'est pas très étonnant
dans le livre de Michel n'a pas
beaucoup d'informations sur les
préparatifs de l'attentat du 11
septembre
envie de poser aujourd'hui à quelqu'un
comme vous qui est mieux informés en
tous les cas que nous est-ce que c'est
un manque de vigilance de la Part-Dieu
avec le CIA où est-ce que certains
éléments des services secrets américains
ont délibérément fait obstruction c'est
pas qu'on leur a demandé de ne pas
intervenir sur ce point-là c'est d'une
part des gens qui préparent des
attentats et qu'il le dise au téléphone
il a tous les quatre matins et que
d'autre part si le pouvoir politique ne
vous demande ne demande pas expressément
un service de renseignement d'avoir pour
objectif de neutraliser par exemple les
groupes terroristes d'origine saoudienne
parce que c'est bien ce sont des groupes
qui sont les religieux qui ont même
contrôler les réserves pétrolière
saoudienne qui représente 25 % derrière
de la planète et bien si le service de
renseignement lui demande pas de travail
et toutes ces informations qu'il
ingurgite sac garni des immenses base de
données qui sont enrichis de milliers
des comptes chaque jour mais qui ne sont
jamais exploité dans le sens où c'est
vrai que après ils ont 76 mois après on
ressort les trucs finalement bien sûr et
puisque c'est l'appareil de
renseignements le plus sophistiqué au
monde et qu'il dispose de moyens
gigantesque donc c'est
un manque de vigilance en fait là c'est
que les États-Unis mais dans ton pays de
la Grande-Bretagne l'Allemagne et la
France était en train de négocier avec
les talibans et aujourd'hui on a un une
preuve incroyable c'est qui a été en
plus fournie par une une caméra de
l'équipe de France 3 de l'émission en
pièces à conviction qui a réussi à avoir
face caméra l'ancien ministre des
Affaires étrangères pakistanais qui
participent aux dernières négociation
secrète qui se dérouler au mois de
juillet 2001 et au cours desquelles un
représentant américain donc été là pour
négocier avec les talibans et donc à
partir du moment où on négocie avec ces
gens-là et bien naturellement on leur
fait pas la guerre où on ne fait pas la
guerre
recette interview face caméra se sait
dans les affaires étrangères pakistanais
affirme que les négociations bloqué et
que les États-Unis le représentant des
États-Unis à adresser une menace de
guerre explicite à ses interlocuteurs
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que on négocier avec eux donc fatalement
où demander un service de renseignement
de travailler contre ces gens-là juste
de les surveiller prudemment et
deuxièmement on leur a quand même donné
des raisons à un moment pour qu'il
radicalise leur action
témoignage
l'anthrax
aujourd'hui
aux États-Unis
les les gens qui avait
envoyé l'essentiel de la journée a plus
de 70 % des lettres étaient des gens qui
travaillait dans une enfant qui était
d'une secte qui s'appelle heart of gold
la secte des notamment aux Antilles
avortements et en fait on a découvert
que au cours des 5 dernières années il
avait en permanence envoyer des lettres
alors parfois avec du vrai entraxe
parfois avec du faux entre et que entre
le 11 septembre et je crois que leurs
études ne s'arrête au 1er février il
n'avait pas plus envoyer de lettre
qu'auparavant donc ça c'est un vrai fait
c'est une vraie histoire sans médiatique
c'est bien attention dessus mais il y a
rien d'extraordinaire manifestement dans
la dans la
[Musique]
Jean Jean elle
mais pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu